everybody's having one team work yeah
makes the dream work here's how it's
everybody's having one or they're fired
so welcome to spotify
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
[ __ ] cute
[Music]
ever done choir no i wish i did i sing
all the time yeah that was that's why i
was asking
yeah i wish i did what did you take as
an elective then
instead were you like a band kid a
theater kid
theater theater dick theater oh [ __ ]
yeah
okay kind of rock that [ __ ] guy kind of
rock
okay theater kid my boy klopp was in uh
dallas was a few weeks ago
he he reminded me how much we cheated
in college this dude cheated his way
through uh what did he call it college
i didn't know you stumbled
like you don't have a degree from a high
school
you know yeah which we've easily proven
yeah
especially like here's a bit for me in
science and he's at a petting zoo
yeah i'm waiting for my mom to text me
back with the pictures here i am at the
cafeteria he's being bottle-fed by
somebody
like why you're you're seven months old
chappelle
yeah i'm on a field trip he's on a date
at a movie theater with his girl
we just wait till my mama sends the
picture she'll text it oh we're waiting
brother yeah
we be waiting it's been two weeks but
we're still waiting yeah
we stay waiting yeah she's just trying
to find it she hasn't like stuffed
around
oh yeah she got it she got it dawg these
uh
funko things are ridiculous they're so
good
what these funko toys these little toys
the cat one's really
cute it's so cute the nick one has a
little izzy azalea shirt on
no one has the oasis t on um
chappelle got an oasis tattoo doug yeah
he did i'm not shocked about that
[Laughter]
chin one i don't know why he gave you a
uh
yours looks like my aunt this one's so
heavy
that's mine do you want mine
damn my guy looks like sh oh dude my
guy's got that hamp shirt on
it's so good damn he's a big ass mma fan
who is this who made this yeah yeah the
guy that made it mm-hmm
spectator spectator he's got he's got an
etsy shop uh
mma custom creations nice wow he's from
australia
oh can you sing brandon although you can
you can buy it for 44.99
and there's king and the staying uh cat
he's selling you
he's telling me i appreciate you putting
shoes on me thank you
[Laughter]
that's so funny cat funko pop
figure yeah how how why how does he do
it
with a printer the printer no no
it's freaking with a 3d printer oh my
toy will be conor mcgregor's toy
[Laughter]
i'm going to get chin one for christmas
it'll go along with my 3d printed that
he that you got it
do you celebrate christmas chin i do
[Laughter]
i do well i want you to jump to
conclusions like a lot of people in here
ethnicities that's true i respect that
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it's on his last leg this thing used to
hype remember we used to have that black
box that just spit music at us
so what is going on uh
with this election dude are we doing
this or what it sounds like we are
i don't know sounds like we have no
choice trump got cove and started
flexing on people said i feel better
don't be afraid
flexing relax well everyone gets upset
like you should be way sicker and dumb
because people
want people to be scared
yeah because then it gives them like
a reason that we shut down for seven
months yeah otherwise we feel real
stupid but y'all seen wuhan oh yeah
we're talking about
how are they doing mm-hmm little party
dude we could party it's just they just
at a distance
no i partied in dallas pretty hard
people are partying everywhere
i just don't know what's going on it's
like just not partying in l.a right
north korea they're partying in l.a
they're just getting their water shut
off too
they're not they're not partying like
this though no one's partying like that
yeah yeah that fine ass dj
oh she looks like a young man
[Laughter]
she looks like your third baseman uh she
might actually
look at that oh whoa whoa whoa whoa what
is
this dude this is that rock are you sure
this might be those refuge honduran
refugees
together without wearing masks that
might be the nike uh
headquarters down on the right
[Laughter]
a lot of topless males there now what do
you think of when you see this
cat well i think it's a beautiful thing
that people are coming together
without the mask i mean apparently china
doesn't need it
they're okay right now yeah everybody's
seen i mean here's the here's how i
think you beat the disease
you just admit that it's [ __ ]
i won back in march
i'm not saying there's not a flu that's
that's out there that's spooky right
but lock up the old people you know if
you're highly susceptible then
then take better precautions if you have
underlying condition if you're out of
shape if you're old keep your ass inside
other than that get your fat ass to work
other than that it just doesn't make any
sense i just don't understand what's
still going on and it starts
to feel kind of like political well yeah
political but also just like
what i just don't it doesn't pass any
logic
at a certain point it's just not making
logical sense it's weird to me people
are
mad that trump's not more sick you know
like i got hate because i wasn't more
sick
what the [ __ ] you want man that's what
it is have you guys ate out in
la like places where there's supposed to
be restrictions it's like i've been
doing it all the time and the second you
get to your seat
you take your mask off yeah and there's
people this is what's weird nick like
you go you go to sign in you have to
have the bike can you put your mask on
i guess you put it on they'll sit you
next to the table you can take your mask
up
i'm like oh but if i'm sitting there i'm
good like yes that makes sense it's just
semantics but restaurants just have
their they have optics it's just optics
it's yeah that's the thing it's just all
become optics what does optics mean
like how does it look it has to look
safe got it even though it's the same
[ __ ] like on the airplanes now they're
you can they're sitting people
everywhere
next to each other like i think you know
delta wasn't doing it for a while some
airlines have been just filling up the
planes like
it just uh like i it just
it doesn't make sense it can't and
there's no way it makes sense to anyone
it's like
i'm not crazy for thinking this like at
a certain point it doesn't make sense to
anyone
yeah i think that's what a lot of it
what it is and a lot of people think
they know the answer to it
so it's like everybody doctors yeah who
really knows the exact
what we're supposed to do with it
meanwhile yeah me maltchan's terrified
of it uh what's this
are you chin yeah no i'm not uh well
he's one of the biggest you had it you
had it and you freaking bro almost
brought it in here we had to put you in
the bag
out i did it for you guys remember that
i did it for you guys
brought it here how do you feel now chin
i feel good
but hey he started it yeah yeah you had
it yeah i think brian started it let's
be real
well dude i mean prove it yeah prove it
prove it yes we can choose a super
spreader prove it
[Laughter]
super spread no i sit right next to cat
talk to her all the time she didn't get
it
bro there's nothing my thing is you got
it though chin look at you
i know you're [ __ ] fine yeah and i
drink every day here's the thing every
day you could have been a model
it could have been a milestone people
that are highly susceptible we should
give
have a stipend for them that get some
money so they can get some help
so they can stay at home so they can
stay at home that's what we should have
otherwise
this it just makes it doesn't make any
sense man
because we're just we're putting
ourselves in this place where there's no
real way out because it's so vague
well then they say well if we had a
vaccine will open back up it's like
we have a vaccine for the flu people
still get the flu yeah
people still die from the flu but not as
many yeah but people still die
all the time yeah and some people don't
care as much if they die some people are
like i don't want to die
oh sorry buddy you know what's this
greedy guy freaking die if you have to
die i'll be an idiot
al michael seems to hate covert
restrictions more than anyone
really does he's you guys were talking
about optics like it was clear
on sunday night him and chris were
standing right next to each other but
then they go on camera and he goes oh if
we're good boys maybe we get lollipops
tonight
i don't even know what he says here
michaels but are i don't know who i am i
think you're chris collins
i'll tell you what they're all so bummed
al's pushing the envelope a little bit
and chris is scared to go along with him
because chris is a company man
that's why a little bit but chris also
when they were doing like the whole
you know protesting black lives matter
he was listen
of course all all black lives matter all
lives matter
because i'm here to call football game
can we move on yeah he like just went
about his business columns were said
[ __ ] articles people are caged up with
nothing left to do but read the articles
there's a lot of [ __ ] we give them
too much credit is what we do we give
articles
agree but there's a lot of [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] happy that
society shut down because give them a
reason to be losers
and he's 75 years old at michael's if he
doesn't want to wear a mask don't make
him wear ass yeah
some people that's the thing you have a
lot of people don't believe in heaven
have no believe in afterlife they don't
care
you know so if they this is all they
have going for them you know
if i die i'm on to the next run bro
there you go you know what i'm saying
dude
i'll be doing cats after spark but i'll
be doing that
i'll be doing cats from the grave yeah
bro you know what i'm saying dude
talk about it tails from the [ __ ] cats
edition
yeah this past funeral maybe maybe it'll
be today if you have to eat eat the
one chip challenge look guys it's about
that time of year and brendan i want to
you know i sometimes with these ads you
know i feel like we just get stuck in
the same thing
yeah the same cadence and it just gets
unprofessional you're right man so i
want to tell you about something right
now people how your wiener don't work
no i'm going to tell you something oh
okay
i have had erectile dysfunction and i
know that
and i know that and that's why this ad
is very important no brendan i used to
think
ed that's what they call it ed was an
issue for old guys but according to the
journal of sexual
medicine by age 40 almost 40 percent of
men struggle with e.d
you're not alone dude i know i'm not
and hems connects you with licensed
medical professionals online to see if
prescription treatment is right for you
yup because you can't figure it out
yourself sometimes
you sit around your penis or your wiener
whatever you have
doesn't work good you do the snake oil
you know
you have somebody come over and beat you
with a snake or somebody hide uh
you know hide a uh raccoon in your house
that's voodoo scaring you in the
erection don't work you do herbs bro a
couple dude named herb come over and see
if they can get it erect you know
doesn't it that means necessary oh i had
somebody hypnotism
dude i got hypnotized right the guy's
like oh your penis will work
i wake up my wallet's missing and
they're wiener's not talking to me no
winners never work
so don't be like that man start right
now go to forehands.com it's all about
men's wellness
also how about hair loss got a cold
interested in mental health or kova 19
home test hymns is here
for you guys yeah you got a cold you got
a warm whatever you got
hymns can help let's tell them the deal
try hymns today by starting out with a
free online visit go to forhims.com
kats 5 for your free visit
that's for hims.com
cats5forhims.comcats5
that's right if you got that low wiener
bro you got that flat patrick
flat patrick prescription product is
subject to medical provider approval and
require an online conversation with a
medical provider who will determine if
the prescription is appropriate
see a website for full details and
safety information remember
for hims.com kats5
hello fresh dog ain't nothing better
than coming home and i got
my meals ready to go man hellofresh
offers convenient delivery right to your
doorstep
easy home cooking look what i'm thinking
when i'm what i'm uh what i'm
struggling with brandon i get home and i
see okay do i have an ingredient to do
us something to do a macaroni to do a
uh casserole cabanaro yes well
take all the guessing out man with
hellofresh and there's something for
everybody what you trying you're trying
to lose weight we got low calorie
you vegetarian we gotcha kid friendly
say no more
you're a little hoe we even got a batch
for you son whatever hoes
hello fresh's carbon footprint is 25
lower than store-bought grocery made
meals keep your fridge stocked by adding
extra proteins or extra sides onto your
order
you know like garlic bread and just
different things that really kind of ups
the ante
it's a great way to spend time with your
family too family that cooks together
you know they're pretty nice to each
other how about that man how about that
dog
go to hellofresh.com 80 cats
use the code 80 cats to get a total of
50 dollars off
across five boxes that's right go to
hellofresh.com
eight zero kats and use code eight zero
kats
to get a total of eighty dollars off
across five boxes including free
shipping
on your first box fresh fill your jowls
baby
this thing listen typical midwest or
nick brings in a food challenge
i feel like this is dangerous i don't
have to go to the hospital dog
they just have to eat it right i i i
want to play
and anybody let's do teams it'll just be
it'll just be
all six of us there's only one person
out of all six of us will have to do it
whoever breaks the ice
on the don't break the ice thing has to
eat it yeah okay
i will die dude uh you like spicy
that's no chin we've seen you grill
spicy food on here yeah
let him know we saw you drink sake and
guzzle spicy [ __ ]
i feared yeah dude we saw you trying to
make a little door dog
yeah trying to molest that white girl
yeah about any of that [ __ ] if you got
shots in here i'll do it in problem
he said he said he'd do shots it's
different a lot of
businessmen asians i'll say it take
drink a lot and take their life
yes yeah yeah okay so this is an
extremely hot
yeah they do chin is a rare you don't
see a lot of guys like chen no five
years from now
chin a couple drinks
i just fall off building i just bought a
gun too yeah yeah
what they play that russian roulette and
[ __ ] bro they play japanese
chinese roulette every chamber is full
of bullets
they flip a coin so what how so we gonna
everybody's in on this
uh yeah everybody in everybody willing
to eat this chip if they lose
yeah [ __ ] it all right she's doing it
for the culture corner
you're not in i can't handle spicy
i can't either but i'm gonna all right
for the control room
you're just going to you're doing that
theo yeah there you go
if chappelle joins if chappelle joins
will you if chappelle joins then
everyone's in then of course i'll have
to come on
now what do you think well listen up
chappelle be honest with us
okay you've obviously had a story career
your father's been in prison you've got
right about
seven families you've been to school you
haven't been to school
black not black backflips yeah back
flips front flips
yeah oasis um wonderwall mia
you know hot topic yeah yeah uh
also now what we need to know is can you
eat this chip
i bet derrick would do it
[Laughter]
derek would do
don't casually try to drop like you
attended junior high
okay
randomly uh pick who goes first so it's
even
cat will be one chappelle two three four
four five that's first
brendon six no and then we'll generate
randomly generate forced death in korean
just so you know
six brendan's first that's a good spot
now it's random and you just
you after you hit one you have to tap
that one out
and multiple is fine you just can't no
it's like jenga
similar yes i did not have a [ __ ]
board available now it's cast iron yeah
the steaks are these things are [ __ ]
hot so what is it then the first person
have to eat the chip
yeah wait why do you got to do this i
don't give you two
that's the rules man whoever loses
whoever makes the penguin
may fall out fall through the ice oh
okay has to eat the chicken
and do it now that packy to
yeah you got to be a uh adventure man
dude you have to be an adventure man
that's how you break the ice gang yeah
damn all right nick
do it for the krusty bunks chapel the
reaper
the reaper i do before do i'm doing it
for uh high school shout out to high
school
that's what i'm doing it for damn you
know the shit's legit one says make sure
you wash your hands after eating do not
eat if you're pregnant keep out of reach
of children
dude pregnant women could handle a hot
chick
if they have a baby a hot cheetos
nothing in there oh
i didn't want to go first that's a bad
spot
to this though not
yeah you can hit that easy one yeah you
can hit that yeah hit the easy one
go ahead i mean i set a trap for him
you can do that not my first rodeo this
is your
what is that an octagon or a square
theo's up
theo's up yeah brendan what are you
doing damn i'm going versus trump
hit the other use the other end use the
other end of the hammer dog that big
daddy what he picked
no stuck so i moved on
i'm about to just eat this chip dawg
don't dog somebody about to [ __ ] [ __ ]
their pants i think
oh [ __ ] oh
nick's on the block man
[Laughter]
i'm so nervous who has to eat this bad
mother man
i i feel like i'm [ __ ] brendan what's
your language dude damn it ooh
wow that one touch they call me one
touch
one touch nick otn they call him one
touch
nick big dog do you wanna read the back
no i don't
chen looking beautiful out here today
guys man give him a cologne or something
there we go boys
if you drop the hammer and it falls
after that you lose yeah yeah
so who's that now chance did taco i
already yeah
i'll smell chin the neck bro chin's out
here [ __ ] looking beautiful dog real
diamy
oh my you got it no but that's not the
one he was hitting oh it was already
there
this one
it's hard
oh no
that's that walker bueller baby saving
the game
son let's go damn good luck brendan
let's
go dude oh my god
[Applause]
they can't handle it they can't handle
the smoke baby
oh god damn you got to get that uh
they can't handle that smoke yeah tell
us how that chip is
yup hey what is it does he get a drink
afterwards or something to help him out
a drink right so chip
picky picky i don't have a chip
i feel like brandon lost i'm sorry dude
[Laughter]
watch the language man god damn it
shin is 50. i am getting there chin is
so
crunk watch no because you kept taunting
us with
like i just wanna know
[Laughter]
or say dang it how about says warning
hurts like hell
oh that only that's just trickery anyone
want to do it with me
i want one i'll do it with you yeah you
want one too yeah i just want a chip
friends i respect that how many of us
have them
friends
yeah everybody's having one team work
yeah makes the dream work here's how
it's everybody's having one or
they're fired
so welcome to spotify
are you really doing this are you yeah
careful also touching the chip don't
touch your eyes
what i got kids man wait i gotta puke
yeah i do
but yeah one of those kids is fine as
[ __ ] too i'll be honest bro
oh yeah yeah that little thicky boy your
comments on
yes shawty die me son
nobody looking spicy this is one chip
yup just one are we just eating a pizza
taking a bite look man
the whole trip dude i know you were you
know you grew up in fear like i did dog
but we're gonna be fine
this one chip you can handle it
chappelle
this is just like a really the craziest
back chip oh mine already broke this
could be the worst episode ever
this could be why did we start off with
this hold on he had the same oh
why is it black i thought it would be
red look i'll tell you straight up man
i'm not trying to be racial but this
thing
but i am but this thing bringing that
dark heat you don't have to eat the
whole thing right
no it's one chip it's like the last dab
if you want to be a big
classic yeah all right i'll do that
i can be that yeah you got to finish no
the rule is i think we eat the whole
chip yeah
we can't go half chipping out here no
one's eating the whole chip
dude it's bueller's day on bro we got
these walker jerseys
that's a real fear everybody's taking
the same time walker bueller brother
[ __ ] wind at night dawg
it doesn't even smell good he's sure
better it looks like wet dog and bologna
huh
so it's like wet dog and bologna is what
it's well nick ate his first
the whole thing holding
oh i'm so scared oh no we have milk on
the way via postmates
what postman did you eat it
how y'all doing i haven't taken a bite
yet
i'm chillin sorry
that powder on it is what had me feeling
risky how you doing nick yes a powder
i'm scared it's fine right now but i can
stop it's
oh it's coming up fast right now chin
space get red
oh yeah it's gonna get soaked oh my god
i'm worried about my insides oh i got
the hiccups oh [ __ ]
here's it oh [ __ ] oh
oh [ __ ] oh did you eat it
chabelle yeah damn outside my tongue's
on fire dog
i'm scared i'm crying i'm still crying
i [ __ ] touched my face
he was crying about it but i'm finna try
it out
so as you can see i ain't bullshitting
man
did they say water makes it worse they
said water makes it worse no did they no
why the
my corner of my mouth is ah
deal you cry pretty
what bro
calm down it's in my nose now don't
touch your face man oh god damn it
here's us what's gonna happen to us
where's the milk yeah where's the bill
bro
yeah i'm lactose intolerant too oh my
gosh
it's
all right
oh
open it up brenden my god
i'm gonna take out my shirt
it's burning my my belly
fellas praying right now oh that milk is
warm
cat you're off you're quiet yep what's
good the cat over here just chillin
cat's sweating a little bit i feel like
every time i talk in birds
all right it's a time for some debate
[Music]
clubs
here's this guy he's got something today
do we have to dude [ __ ] this guy bro i
need a water
[ __ ] this guy dude nick will give me
water
bro quiet california
connecticut she's taking care of me here
when i'm looking for jobs
bro we can't even [ __ ] think
and he has this mask on it can't read
this that's not gonna help
let me get that gatorade you wanna get
ready do you not want it
looking for a job
who doesn't wanna see your feet gang
gang socks off
are we supposed to eat more food i don't
know what to do
give me something i need to eat more
chips yeah
i'll grab some more food thank you bro
it's starting to die out for me yeah
sure
oh that damn it's carbohydrates so i
don't want carbs
it's zero sugar okay i'll get it
still on diet huh
thank you sir thank you dr pepper
the dumbest thing i've ever done
theo took a big bite all right one more
stop i feel like we're too old for this
my stomach hurts
[Music]
you're a beautiful crier yeah you
[Laughter]
does it creep up again i don't need to
calm down bro
y'all
don't be one of them spice guys
cheers to autism we just rearranged our
chromosomes is that what this is for
autism
no that those were your last lines when
you did hot ones
oh is anyone else's like intestines
burning do you know how it was
what'd you say is anyone's like bottom
intestines burning yeah my stomach's
burning my mouth died down [ __ ] is
powerful
i'm straight i was hot i'm straight now
i'm good how are you doing
theo i'm good was that hotter than
which is hotter i'll tell you what this
chip was hotter
really you know this [ __ ] just feels
like okay it's remodeling me bro
actually you know it feels like a nose
no one of them yeah
what's the oil sand one of them what
i don't know leave me alone
you're saying gay stuff chappelle i got
a [ __ ] cry for you so pretty when you
cry
oh thank you man with a hat on too damn
right
were oh those god they didn't put a lot
of spice on the wings
that's the difference this chip had more
spice on it yeah
one of the spices there was spicy
nine of them were not
y'all did the big bites bro i was like
man [ __ ] this did you not eat the whole
chip hey oh my god
and you're acting like this bro it's
still spicy you a [ __ ]
i'll take it you [ __ ] i'll take it you
pretty when you cried too
hello fam one's enough doug
yeah your dad was the one in prison dawg
[Laughter]
using these prison lyrics are you half
of that son [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm on my third stevia
oh what did we do that for autism nick
yeah what was yeah
i think nick said he had an extra
chromosome or something
nick b lined up the room nick coming 30
minutes late with milk
that milk was warm dude that milk made
me feel more sick than [ __ ]
i was ashamed of myself me too yeah who
[ __ ] drinking milk
it was disgusting oh you don't drink
milk at all
dog no homo bro i drink half the milk
or yes homo all homo yeah
and that means homogenized as well
damn it it's ultra pasteurized bro i
feel bad
yeah what'd they do to him that's a lot
melts disgusting
no [ __ ] oh and i'm like just no
i don't even want this man why are we
living like this dude why did nick do
this to us this is what it's like in
some countries brendan
india they have spices eyes burn your
face burns
huh how's your mouth my the top of my
tongue is is actually
reheated now that's like it goes in and
out like the sides of my tongue
yeah what the hell sides sizes i think i
should have swallowed it faster you
should probably
even eat it dog yeah don't try jumping
on this train yeah dude
did you have your whole chip cat yep wow
the whole chip you got to eat the whole
chip can't handle your whole chip i'm
pretty good with spice
but women handle things better than men
yeah
look everybody's got certain issues dude
you know
and a lot sometimes people think they
wean or ain't decent
sometimes think it's small but really
it's just covered with the weeds
yeah so trim them bad boys trim them bad
boys get that let that thing breathe a
little bit
bushes aren't in anymore thank the
manscape manscape has the performance
package it's the ultimate men's hygiene
bundle
i'm talking about this nude package has
the weed whacker for your ears
and your nose theory does two of them at
the same time
dog two at the same goddamn time the
bundle also includes the lawnmower 3.0
the best trimmer on the market for your
balls and your body all right
tighten your balls tighten your body get
the performance package now to receive
their two free gifts that's manscape
boxers and the shed travel bag
look shy bro you don't want to show up
to the family reunion with a bunch of
bush hair though get a philly fade on
your nut sack the performance package is
the best value that manscape has to
offer get 20
off free shipping with the code king
sting at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use the code king sting
what are you waiting for go whack your
weeds look i want to say something to
everybody out there
because everybody knows i struggle with
mental health and
what are you talking about no you're
right dog i everybody knows i struggle
with mental i struggle with it
brendan is just a complete victim of
mental health
okay i both struggle with it no you more
so than me but yeah but yours is more
education
uh education lacking i feel like where i
actually have something wrong with my
brain dude yeah i know you choose to
have something wrong
but there's something you can do about
it that's the thing though doug like you
can get help you can get better help you
know what i'm feeling bro brendan's
dressed like a hit man for
bubble gum i feel like you've been
chewing or not huh
you've been chewing or not boy um i'll
say this man
if there's something interfering with
your happiness uh
and you don't know what it is and it's
preventing you from achieving your goals
it could be that you need some help and
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist professionals the
key
quit listening to your friends if your
friends aren't making you happy quit
getting advice from friends i'm talking
about a real professional
therapist you know what i'm saying
better help once you start living
happier
right now visit their website bunch of
people on there over a million people
are out there taking charge of their
mental health with the help of
experienced professionals
in fact so many people using better help
they started recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states on god baby
it's betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s special offer for king and the
sting listeners get 10
off your first month if you need to
experience it then try it
you know i just reached out to a new
therapist i'm excited about jumping onto
a skype with them
um and you know it's just an opportunity
yeah it's a tool it's a tool you got to
sharpen you you got to sharpen your tool
man
betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
ice cream would be so good right now
vanilla ice cream ice cream oh yeah do a
slurpee right now it sounds like
i'm looking for anything
dude this is no time to be fat dude
you eat the whole chip because you try
and put the bottle nick you eat the
whole chip
did you eat the whole chip yeah that was
the agreement
it's one [ __ ] chip son i got high
blood pressure
so do i yeah but does that do anything
to it
i want to find out i don't know no man
it's weird i just my stomach feels
like it's churning and my tongue is
getting hot again yeah it feels like
someone stabbed me in the stomach
okay i'm almost back i'm bad i'm cool i
can cook
so who else cat handled it the best
easily
chappelle didn't qualify you
disqualified she also got a whole ass
chip over there dude how much you got
left hold that up hold that up the
camera come on
hold it up all of it yeah no no he has
that piece
and a huge you pick your baby hold it up
hold it up
and away from your body off to the side
look at that put it by the white wall
just so we can see it
could mess it around
we can yeah so so we can see the chip
there we go your little way your little
big ass ain't a freaking little
baby body dog had a nibble then started
acting like he ate the whole thing like
yeah and he's saying you beautiful dog
like that gay dude at the sleepover
trying to get you all drunk wait so
everybody ate the whole chip
yeah yeah man everybody gangsters are
gonna do it
yeah you do it the rest of the show's
gonna
be if you do it swallow it faster
because it's
it's burning the top of my tongue right
now okay all right
i'm shocked bro do what you're doing oh
represent the black community poorly
today bro
sorry i will say that i got to do it huh
it's your people though hey man
blm dog oh my god damn
oh you're taking too long to swallow it
oh you take too long just swallow it
don't spit it out no [ __ ] up you got
to stay with me oh you took too long to
swallow it
okay cattle nursery cat will help you no
why did you guys make sure
do that you didn't eat it oh no
no do you want to come back he's running
to the bathroom he's [ __ ]
yo gay bro gay cat film him
god get your filmer out filmer
there's nobody in there and look there
ain't a man in there that's for sure
okay you beautiful when you cry dawg we
gotta give him
hell and then he kept saying it yeah
give him a polygraph your lips get all
pouty when you get eat spicy
stuff yeah what like damn you look
beautiful when you
he's like oh that shirt goes with your
tears i'm like
bro we need to give him a dang uh test
man
that gay test i think we just did he ran
out the room
that chip's really a gay test if it
burns you inside
you ain't christian i mean he was coming
in did he seem a little gay to you shin
i saw a real fear the first time i
actually saw real fear but i'm not
asking you
now i'm not saying did he seem scared i
said did he see him i say it a little
bit
maybe a little bit you know what i'm
saying you guys are [ __ ] up though
this is where you [ __ ] up
he's like i get the whole thing i gotta
chew it i'm like yeah but do it fast but
you didn't listen
and so he's really he i know that thing
up like
i'm telling him he's [ __ ] his mouth i
told him i told him to see the way he
chewed it
oh dude he just like coated his tongue
yeah i'm good i'm good so you think i'm
back
let's get into the episode yeah someone
stabbed me in the stomach but i'm fine
my mouth's fine yeah don't do that again
nick
this guy sounds like a deadbeat i've
seen people say oh do hot ones do hot
ones we did that
yeah that was beyond hot that was hotter
man
the only thing is that was more spice
that was the thing
there was more spice in that hot one
they don't do that much spice bro
i'm glad that brendan lost because i
feel like if it would have been like
one of the crew it would they would just
split down on their own
you know like i think everybody doing it
together yeah that was fun that's the
way to do it
where the [ __ ] do you play [ __ ] looks
more asian after you did it
your eyes are no i swear it's i swallow
and bloat
very fast wow you're like one of those
fish
i am like blow fish when i eat ramen
boom my face i can't even see
yeah the spicy ramen sodium
oh my god
he's fine i'm a little worried about now
me too he kind of gave me a headache
guys
you guys have no faith in different uh
cultures then
he's fine is a black man okay
he his people have been through tons of
[ __ ] he can handle one
spicy chip it didn't look like you guys
like i don't know it's the way he chewed
it though that's going to give him
the way he chewed it have you seen
[ __ ] amazon dude
and that's the penalty for being a
coward yeah
yeah bro but then that's a penalty for
being coward and also getting real gay
after you eat that chip
he kept commenting on theo's cheers he
took a body
bite of it hold on he took a nibble of
it and then he goes
you look so tense and i'm like what yeah
they kept going
you all two should relax more why
doesn't cat get out of here yeah
i wonder if there's any restaurants that
are open at night
for us i'm like what
what are you talking about i'm worried
about us we should all stay over my
place
yeah yeah yeah what did he oh he's like
what if the power
keeps going out i'm like what it hasn't
gone out
you guys want to see this this is insane
dude
i was like well i had a great time did
you have fun and i'm like what did
should be the darkest care bear that's
his new nickname
the darkest dark beer because he is
leave him out there this is a learning
time
this is a learning time this is a good
oh
he's okay he's able to speak he's just
gargling milk
oh my gosh bring up somebody that was in
a fire
victim bring up someone that was in an
actual fire and let me see or google
burn victim or black history
i'm just saying there are people that
have really really suffered you know
what's the famous picture of the
vietnamese woman
burning in the fire remember at the war
oh no she's protesting
no no that's a there's a monk that put
himself on fire
he didn't move at all that's real dog
that was a postmate no he was doing the
same competition weird
[Laughter]
there we go same competition cover over
rage against machine albums yeah he's
doing the same competition there we go
we brought him back but yeah yeah we
brought him back with the cover
how's your mouth though chappelle i
didn't owe it quick enough i know
i don't know i chewed it like that bro
you did not need to do all that
but at least you went through something
yeah i went through something i
appreciate y'all pushing me do you feel
better to do something that
you know you put you put me out of my
comfort zone and really pushed me
and that was uh yeah that was uh i just
thank you guys
how's your insides he's going to be fine
what do you mean
he's inside he's fine dude i'm good
inside right mine's feeling
my mouth your mouth my mouth is nothing
my sister y'all will
stab me my stomach is then y'all wimps
what do we have nick you had
tears coming up yeah i wasn't doing well
i think this is the perfect the perfect
time
thank you don't let him say it again
he's your friend uh
so we when we had little browsing okay
everybody said enough kind of gay stuff
on this episode
and i'm not pointing names or fingers at
anybody
okay but i feel like we've hit
kind of a the gay
the gay meters here chappelle nietzsche
he was in a movie crying and [ __ ] i
cried with you
no more snacks for you man at least now
we know why he didn't want to eat spicy
foods
that makes him gay i don't blame him
yeah dude
[Laughter]
i can't wait to get back to my szezwan
gang
back to my squad
oh what do you got nick we have a uh
laotian kid on our team
that's cool uh no lay ocean
lao lao oh one of the lao yum yum
is his nickname that's what it says on
his jersey little young huh little yum
yum i call him yum yum double yum
yum huh yum i say yum
and i tickle him when i run by a second
base
i ain't tickling you bro you're not even
allowed to comment on anything that's
potentially getting your house yeah you
threw so much gay sauce this way down i
got a man pretty when he cried
yeah multiple times
yeah okay you brought something out of
your eyes man damn bro
you gotta calm down buddy
don't break the ice i'll tell you what i
saw
all right let's get some questions in
here let's get somebody in here who
hopefully is
what's going on man can you hear us
what's up yeah i can hear you can hear
me
so this is the fella that uh we talked
about last week
invited uh theo out to go fishing in
nashville
what's up bro i owe you a big apology
first of all because we accidentally put
your phone number on the episode
oh yeah yeah yeah we just ate some spicy
chips we've had a kind of a tough day uh
why spicy makes people gay yeah i wanted
to see man if you would still
be willing to take me fishing i'm sorry
about the phone number thing man it was
an accident
and it was my fault but um but yeah i
was gonna come maybe night uh
into this week or next week if you if
you still wanted to go man i'd love to
go one day
and also sorry uh if you flip your phone
vertical you'll be able to see brendan
theo
should there we go holla
yeah sorry about that man yeah i just
wanted to apologize man it was an
accident
and and if it messed up your phone or
anything you know i'd be more than
willing to pay for your phone bill or do
whatever to help out
you will do give a new phone i would
just love to say you have some
great fans and you also have some real
weirdos
oh did you get some weird text brother
yeah
ben from south carolina definitely a
weirdo
no no no uh penis picks that's where i
was going to draw the line and change my
number but i didn't get any of those do
you get any suicidal threats anything
like that
uh no not suicidal theo mentioned i was
either a nice guy or a murderer and some
people were trying to like put that to
the test
like seeing if i would come kill them
hold on it was just some weird stuff
yeah yeah that seems that's almost
asian in a lot of ways dude i'm just
north
of nashville from where you've probably
been hanging out yeah um
and yeah i'd love to hang out dude we've
got some good spots me and one of my
buddies love to go
um just chill out relax by the water so
yeah that'd be a great time man yeah man
well i'll hit you up then uh
i'll text you whenever we get done with
the show today but um but yeah there's
no
checks right yeah no chicks probably but
yeah we but we can talk about them you
know we can talk about chicks and you
can show pictures
yeah we're getting that pic we have have
them in our in our heads while we're out
there but no man i'm looking forward to
it dude i'd love to get out there and do
some fishing so i appreciate it and
and yeah man if you still take me man
i'll go out there with you guys uh
yeah this week or next week just
whenever you guys go again
yeah for sure cool man well i appreciate
it yeah sorry again man yeah and i guess
there's a lot of freaks out there a lot
of perverts i know that
i just let my number accidentally on uh
last week's king in the stream
oh what happened uh i i just put it up
on the screen and the screen record it
was when we were looking at the uh
the eggs in that and it like auto
populated thing
i had some people hitting me i've left
mine before and uh
i've gotten hundreds of texts from
people some there's a man that will not
leave me alone
is it the dude from south carolina ben i
don't know i haven't looked at the air
what the area code is but
but yeah man sorry about that and yeah
i'm looking forward to it dude so we'll
go uh i'll hitch up i'll drop you a text
whenever i get done and we'll go uh this
week or next week next time you guys are
free yeah sounds good brother all right
we appreciate it man thank you for your
patience
see you man damn all right cheers i was
gonna ask what species of fish they
catch there
oh he's still there oh yeah just all the
bass man some crappie maybe
oh [ __ ] sweet want your butt
want your boys quit being gang go
noodling get your hands dirty dog
get in there some catfish man crappie's
the ticket
well he's in the gay part but maybe yeah
hey man that's what i'm saying bro
noodling on ladies get your shirts off
start
noodling doug well hannah baron's gonna
come on uh this past weekend and
sometime next month
so maybe after she sees this maybe we
can get her to go uh
fishing with us one day yeah let's do it
that'd be awesome that'd be crazy but uh
she's doing elk hunting or something
right now damn she killing elk i guess
she's gonna kill her
what we should do is when i go to
nashville we drive down and shoot [ __ ]
with hannah oh that'd be crazy
maybe she'll come up then but yeah man
i'll i'll hitch up and we'll go man i'm
excited i'm ready to go dude i'm ready
to go get on some
my insides are good all right be good
brother have a good one
appreciate joe cheers man thank you
we could uh record a king in the sting
from theo's nashville studio
like we could the crew could just be
here zoom in
have hannah baron in the culture corner
oh we could probably do that
i'm down for that are you flying early
too if you want to do that or whatever
you want to do
if i make it my my insides are in fuego
family
what it didn't bother my mouth too bad
but my insides are dying
yeah your mouth you didn't get that torp
you you ate it fast was that your skill
yeah i didn't do that i kind of tried to
taste it a little
not me i deep-throated that thing
what is wrong with all of y'all man
nothing bro but every time i come back
here dog i'll be honest bro y'all be
gayer bro that's l.a bro
damned huh y'all need to get out there
though
uh cat the only straight one in here man
baby there's no other girls in here theo
just made a blind date with some dude
that's a fan of his
yeah me and my boy take you out now all
right
i'll be hitting you up next week man
he's like that sounds fun
and i was like yeah maybe i should
invite a girl he's like nah don't do
that
you mean a witness no way
i'm a little dizzy are you y'all are
straight
up [ __ ] dude i didn't say i can't
function now
but y'all need to tighten up dude here's
a guy right here who obviously is doing
something at the house
with a mask what up brendan
culture corner nick and chin this is dre
from lakewood california right
member of the thick boy walkers club got
a
debate club for you or maybe some uh
relationship question for you
quit my job first week of march to go
freelance and then two weeks ago
pandemic shut me down
so i got out of california and i was
staying with my girlfriend connecticut
she's taking care of me here when i'm
looking for jobs you know it sounds like
nick's freaking history i put my clothes
in so i stopped dipping out of my
suitcase
so my question is you should i quit
looking for work and just stay here let
her take care of me
or continue looking for a job clearly an
apartment with those blinds homeboy
[Laughter]
right now
i live in an apartment brendan yeah i
know you do but you
choose to live there he shouldn't be he
has no choice he should be milking off
his girlfriend in that one bedroom
apartment dog
once you add something to the
relationship go out and get a job
homeboy yeah let me listen let me tell
you this buddy
you are you talking to him or me huh
you're talking to me or he's talking to
him i'm not sure
okay go fire you got to get out there
and do something to help out you can't
be
getting up and pretending like you're
going to go do a job and then your lady
leaves and you go get back in the bed
yeah
play video play video games on you being
lazy dude you being nasty you can't
sleep in your car
and think you're gonna become a freaking
gambler a regionally successful gambler
yeah don't act like you're part of the
sick boys walking club because there is
not one
there isn't no it's a [ __ ] bike club
bro yeah get a bike man get your [ __ ]
together
don't squash this guy's dreams anything
can happen yeah my bad
yeah so i think yeah look anything can
happen man and you figured it out
yeah look at nick [ __ ]
i'm lightheaded whoa whoa did you order
this guy
is this an is this an extra from
american history actually
bro this guy looks like abe lincoln a
little doesn't he with that but with uh
no hat
i guess you've never seen him with that
oh no did he have a beard he had a beard
hell yeah
theo brandon love you guys
got a debate club since theo always
talks about
getting more mexicans in the nba amen
that's the best name
got juancho herman gomez nba player
panthers just an nfl draft shout out to
brandon and football just drafted
yator gross matos i think that's a
pretty good name
then my favorite rapper his name is hood
rich
pablo juan what's the best name guys
and let's get more mexicans in the nba
he doesn't look mexican who is he horner
i don't think he said he was mexican
yeah he's just not mexican he's down i'm
down for it
but you're nicaraguan bro yeah but and
also i'm i'm on food's gone wild
tomorrow it's okay who's going wild the
food's going wow my favorite favorite
we can just we can just do verify them
i'll tell you straight up bro i'm down
with [ __ ]
though we introduced latin names in
general how about benito santiago
dude the most mexican you can get bro is
probably
hector hector
cocaine julian junior
dude i'm gonna hit you with this you
[ __ ] whities how about jeff
garcia
he's mexican mexican redhead jeff
garcia there's a lot of mexican redheads
dude that's bad
fool you don't know a real fool when you
see one look at the full starter kit
look at him he's mexican oh i got a good
jeff garcia story what you got doug
so i was in yanfrance
one of the first and only stops on the
gay train uh and uh
and he spilled wine on a new shirt that
i just got from banana republic why did
he spill wine on you what were you guys
doing
he fumbled it i don't know i was
drinking wine and he was uh playing and
he was dude where was this
at where at a nice place brendan okay
i went to a nice place with a friend
there was a rumor that jeff was gay for
a long
time but then he came out with a picture
of him in some honeys and said shut the
[ __ ] up
did they yeah he had a picture of him in
a box you don't have to curse every time
about it
i'm sorry it's because uh tyrell owens
told playboy
that jeff garcia was gay and jeff said
cool
then jeff said cool hold my chicks and
there's a bunch of there's pictures of
him a bunch of chicks did anybody waste
their talent with their mouth more than
terrell owens i wonder
uh wasn't he like at the best and then
he just all fell apart he's really good
i mean he kind of just got old he was he
was always famous he was still good on
dallas for
his last he was good on philly too with
the super bowl he had one leg and
balled out yeah maybe you're right he
was always a diva though he always had
problems with all quarterbacks
he beat the packers in the 1997 playoffs
he caught it and he started crying
that's my quarterback with the niners
that's what he said yeah start crying
that's my quarterback
yeah just talked about tony romo i think
though yeah it doesn't sound like garcia
is the one that's really having some
hormonal issues
hold up shout out ucla has one of the
dopest mexican basketball players dog
he's el futora
shout out to mexican culture shit's
tight yeah except for the violencia at
the dodgers games
that is not cool i'm gonna go on record
right now if you are mexican
and you are in the upper stands of the
dodgers games threatening
people up there yeah people that could
be sitting there high on cocaine trying
to enjoy the game
and you keep yelling
and then when i say you're going to kill
me then you say or someone's going to
kill you
that ain't cool bro okay way to [ __ ] up
your high huh
yeah you make my height come down
oh you make my heart dog i'm not feeling
good
i am not i'm wondering your stomach huh
quit complaining dog i'm light-headed
i'm getting soft bro
no i'm i'm good i'm good you look like
my clothes from uh bloody
blood out thank you y'all are getting
[ __ ] soft foams
where's that guy again ricky rodriguez
yeah a bunch of cabrons
yeah gabron who's the ucla guy nicholas
oh he
i think i just closed it [ __ ]
how you feeling over there chin awfully
quiet dude i'm
actually feeling wild by the way a
little refreshed like you feel a little
woke you up right this is baby they say
spicy stuff makes you lose weight
maybe because you don't want to eat
anything after he should be playing for
ucla right now yeah that's last year
mexico city kid
yeah men's basketball jaime jacquez
right there junior
mia what's the first guy
damn look at him dog number four
jaime how do you say that
cat it's from uh i have no idea
well six six well the j is an h yeah
yeah i think it's hackies
junior and he's a straight up g i heard
baller he shoots 45 percent put the
dunk on you put them chimichanga nuts in
your face dog
i respect it he has 26 points a game
last year no way
no nine is he still in college oh yeah
nine if you have 26 he's going sizzler
to the nba dog you average nine
minutes oh 26 minutes ooh dang sorry
okay but he's good bro i'm telling you
bro yeah he seems all right
dude first of all yeah he's fresh he's
freshman bro
damn he's a freshman mexican dude at
ucla crushing the game
yep wait he's not from mexico he's just
mexican right well he's mexican american
cat
yeah because he's like my kids he's like
my kids he looks like richie valens a
little bit
he does great set of hair on him
mexicans have great they got that good
they do
they have great good hair like thick
curly hair yeah
when they slick it back yeah my bottom
bottom lip is on fire it's coming back
kids there he is right there with you
balance man
don't need a spicy chip around him do
that right now
do not eat a spicy chip around him
you think chappelle's gayness was hot
you think richard allen might have been
getting
no man y'all homophobic
y'all homophobic what's this uh nick uh
we talked when little brows
uh joined the culture corner about
possibly putting together a king and a
sting album
and uh he really went ham on it and it's
it's happening
dog i've heard some of the tracks the
one with him and chin about hannah baron
it is fan fighter
get down on the wall oh man all the way
to alabama
there's some originals yeah
you always leave us wanting more there's
some original songs by brows and there's
a bunch of the
our favorite submissions from the show
uh it's gonna drop someplace
on vinyl or digital copy late november
early december
wow if on november first uh we're gonna
open up fi or
cap the meet me at 20 tier on our
patreon at 500 spots and if you're a
patreon member on november 1st you will
get the first run
of those [ __ ] uh shipped to you
yeah that's cool and this is the debut
album off it uh
we filmed it a couple weeks ago this
one's called chapelle lacy
that's a good name for a song lebron
turn that [ __ ] up
chappelle down oh damn got some video
[Music]
vixen
[Music]
my [ __ ] is
[Music]
showing up
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
degrees
look at nick
[Music]
is
[Music]
little brown's so talented
[Music]
gang man
[Laughter]
isn't that video great yeah they crushed
you that's cool man
you guys did a great job
so there's more to come with that and he
mentioned paul paul wall if you want to
feature on this album hit us up if
you're watching i'm trying to get mike
stud on there too
damn yeah and we want to get jelly roll
on another one
anybody yep that'd be crazy man that's
not
crazy man if i'm alive to see it i hope
i don't feel good
you don't you'll be fine man so we're
gonna do a limited edition
first run only a thousand copies 500
will go to patreon
the other 500 will sell but it's gonna
have artwork that will never be used
again if we decide to
print more vinyl wow and i'm trying to
before i pass away i'm trying to
yeah some people do actually what i
think we should do is a live king the
sting with the
live musical artist chin little brows
you
me be sick chappelle where though the
war we can't do that much
yeah you can like places in texas wide
open
yeah nashville is open right florida
wide open
live cube that would be oh that'd be
dope you half me and theo doing our
thing on stage half
live show it's like lollapalooza for
cats
i think i think it's easier than uh
doing stand-up if we have to use an
outdoor venue i think it like lends
itself more to that
like the festival feels like outdoors
could work we can rip rip people's drip
in person
videos it should be easy yeah i think uh
doing something like that would be
interesting for sure
fun cats festival you have live music
doing stand up and [ __ ] this is uh king
in the sting 91
maybe we could try to plan it for king
and the sting 100. oh
that'd be about nine weeks i'm dead
we'll discuss
you feeling froggy jump nashville boy
where did we do it that's the thing
where did we do it at well let me figure
that out if you down i'll figure that
out
yeah yeah because i could drive to
somewhere if it's over there if it's
close to here
i mean it'd be easiest if it was in
california probably
california's too locked down you think
yeah you can't do it here
we we could do it amarillo maybe you
could do it in texas you're in nashville
florida those are the three big ones
albuquerque i've always wanted to go to
albuquerque
oh i haven't been there i've done
stand-up in albuquerque yeah how long
ago
three years ago probably what they got
to call did you do theater or club is
there uh it was a casino club
it's pretty top club well what else
we got a little bit more time let's do a
debate club let's see what this guy has
right here he's a young guy who's
obviously been dealing with something
right here do i know him andrew
gang buzz buzz what up chappelle nick
chin give me that cat hitter
got a debate club for you guys i think
this is a real good one
who's the best dancer black guys
or girls or asians
oh bad guys chappelle versus chin
get it going why don't we just do gang
gang buzz buzz can you dance
i mean we can play some music you guys
want to dance right here we already know
who won this battle
wow i don't think we know that well
jabbawockeez though like koreans can
dance
bts bts but she isn't one of those
but that's like 12 koreans there's a
k-pop is huge and then [ __ ]
dance dance i was given different gifts
not dancing i can't move my body like
jabbawockeez what do you think
sh cat how many are you talking about
chin and chappelle or
black people versus asians i think black
people
naturally dance better but asians if
they
trapped us then yeah if they have like
choreography they kind of train
than them but i think naturally black
people just kind of
black people have rhythm they have
rhythm they have asians have work ethic
they're going to beat them into those
pop lock and drop and different dances
too because break dancing i would say
asians
all skyrocketed big in korea yeah yeah
yeah yeah like hip-hop
hip-hop the red bull breakdancing
competition
and do you all um what is that but where
did it come from
i know thank you yeah they rock and roll
too culture
culture vultures did black people teach
korean people how to dance
culture vultures where no
or some koreans probably like when
breakdancing like first popped off they
probably looked at it was like damn
that's kind of dope
yeah inspired it just like evolved and i
think they just took it to another like
level like culture i could maybe see
some of that i just don't know if there
was like a ship of korean people that
went to africa
yeah apparently the biggest like
interracial couple over in africa right
now
are uh the chinese and africans that's
hot damn
so there's a lot of boys can you google
that nick
chinese african couples hot there's a
lot who's a blasian who's the famous
karuchi tiger woods
part vietnamese um the rapper yeah he
his mom is half vietnamese half black
but that dick all black
[Laughter]
yo all right all right guys
all right you didn't see the crazy
you ain't on the only fans account then
of tiger
you would know he's packing heat yeah
holy fan's account yeah
he put his big old dangling pick on
there no way
he put his four dingy
and it's good see i didn't say that kind
of [ __ ]
yeah but it's worse just not yeah but
you eat a spicy chip you're gonna start
saying different things
yeah look i ain't taking you to prison
home yeah
oh benson henderson yep
yeah honeymoon yup benson henderson did
we just talk to him
no what he's a fighter right
he's he's a uh rival of michael
chandler's oh yes
oh bruno mars i don't think he's black
though no bruno mars
he's puerto rican and filipino yeah yeah
that will demps guy he's like super
handsome
all the girls i knew he was a safety for
the baltimore i mean he's that's a wild
that's awesome yeah that's an old-school
reference but he's good looking hyde's
ward was sweet
again old school oh man
fat as [ __ ] now dog he was always kind
of thick right
yeah best blocking wide receiver of all
time
all right
[Laughter]
there's a girl right now her name is
joyce rice black and korean she's
gorgeous joyce rice joyce rice what's
she look like
you could google it imagine it bro
she takes the cake as far as baddies who
are half black half
japanese karuchi oh
joyce rice
how's that not a game show huh whose
rice is it anyways
you feel me no you're not feeling that
no that's not that good the price is
rice is better
nah it's too easy whose rice is it
anyways dude
that's a show about starvation no
they gotta fight for food yeah i think
that's the hunger games no
the price is right come on down
brandon who is the one you said karuchi
she's so cute
someone that did chris brown she's
dating uh
she's got a shot in the court didn't she
no no no that's meg
it's karuchi k-a-u-r-t
[Laughter]
what bothers me is that it spelled it
for him yeah
it's like already in the system k-a-r
baffling
you better educate yourself nick
she's modest um
she's pretty modest she's out of
afghanistan huh
yeah she's pretty man she was she was
nick uh chris brown's girl forever but
she's
dating she's with cruz yeah tom cruise
no
victor cruz who's that retired
yeah retired giants receiver
yeah first team all zaddy well
well well whose rice is it anyways
[Music]
rice is right i feel like drew carey
sold his
soul to do that show he's great at it
all the time yeah i think you definitely
come on down
just every five you have to love it no
yeah i love money i think you would lose
it after a while uh
of the first two weeks you're like oh
that's a cool gig you can do this my
week four is like
[ __ ] dude he seems pretty affable though
he just gets to like joke around with
the people and stuff
he's yeah if they want it's like a new
car like it'll be that guy
yeah he's a great tipper by the way
i worked at a hotel he tipped for
anything you gave them directions
well that's not price is right money yo
i got to start tipping more
i tip a lot nobody to tip right now good
for you i'm a good tipper but i got a
tip i just need to tip more often
like if i see somebody just tip them i
guess you gotta do a giant amount so
then it goes viral
like theo vaughn left two thousand
dollars for a pregnant waffle house
waitress yeah yeah you like waffle house
i i like it yeah i will have cool yeah
i haven't had it in a minute i'll take
the kids over there because they don't
get out of line because there's too much
[ __ ] going on in the joint you know
somebody else is already there's already
an adult that's out of line and so the
kids are like
kids you know if i throw a fit in here
it doesn't matter that guy's got a gun
you know
yeah that guy's eating his waffles with
two guns
so this is different but
is that it kids that's it that is uh i'm
back on the road i'm in uh
phoenix early november i think first
week in november phoenix stand up live
and i'm in nashville november hey man
asheville doug
next thursday don't be scared don't be
scared tampa
this weekend yeah october 15th through
the 18th
tickets are on chapelle lacey.com
tonight
fancy tonight you're you'll be at side
splitters splitting sides
put inside splitting sideways boys in a
day
they split inside don't eat spicy food
i don't know where i'm going to be but
you can find me
i do need to go to st louis i've been
there a long time oh i don't want to
[Laughter]
so we'll see man i got to find some
spots to go
we'll see i'm going to do some shows in
nashville but i just don't know where
yet so
that's all i got all right dog okay
brendan and theo
fighter and weight i got to go in and go
hard in the paint i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go i need a sponsor i am a
monster about to open up with this at my
concerts flow is contagious browser
outrageous thicker than girls that are
instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
travel couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me
[Music]
up
king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string